soyez les bienvenus l'ordre du jour
appelle les questions au gouvernement
la parole est à monsieur damien meslot
merci le studio le président monsieur le
président ma question à laquelle
j'associe mes collègues frédéric reiss
et michel zumkeller s'adresse à monsieur
le premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre le 8 septembre dernier la
direction d'alstom transport a annoncé
la fermeture de son site de production à
belfort
cette annonce a eu l'effet d'un coup de
massue en effet ce sont plus de 400
emplois directs et 900 emplois indirects
qui sont menacés belfort est le berceau
historique de production d'alstom
transport depuis 137 ans c'est à belfort
que les premières motrices tgv ont vu le
jour et 7 à belfort que se trouve
l'essentiel du savoir faire français en
matière de construction ferroviaire
alstom transport un carnet de commandes
de 30 milliards d'euros et réalise plus
de 3 milliards d'euros de bénéfices le
site de belfort un carnet de commandes
suffisantes jusqu'en 2018 et doit
produire le tgv du futur à partir de
2021 il y as dont 4 ou de production de
3 ans à combler en mai 2015 emmanuel
macron était venu à belfort pour nous
assurer de la pérennité du site et 18
mois après on nous annonce sa fermeture
l'état détient 20% du capital d'alstom
est en mesure d'intervenir sur bon
nombre de marchés vous êtes engagé avec
le président de la république à sauver
le site alstom de belfort
nous prenons acte de vos déclarations
mais nous voulons maintenant des
décisions concrètes et plus seulement
des belles paroles
c'est pourquoi je vous demande de tenir
votre engagement de sow et le site de
belfort comme nicolas sarkozy l'avait
fait en 2004 et de m'indiquer quelles
actions vous entendez prendre pour
sauver ceux ci et sauvegarder les 1300
emplois concernés les familles
belfortaine attendent votre réponse je
vous remercie
merci monsieur meslot la parole et à
monsieur christophe sirugue secrétaire
d'état chargé de l'industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés et monsieur le
député damien meslot une histoire à
savoir faire une fierté
tous ces éléments nous les avons en tête
lorsque nous examinons bien sûr la
situation du site de belfort d'alstom à
la demande du président de la république
le gouvernement s'est mobilisé dès
l'annoncé qui a été faite sans
concertation avec le gouvernement et qui
est venu marquer très fortement votre
territoire
nous avons eu d'ailleurs l'occasion
d'échanger ensemble et nous le faisons
régulièrement je vous en remercie parce
que je crois que nous sommes sur un
sujet qui doit à la fois être traités
avec responsabilité eu égard aux enjeux
économiques sociaux et avec le suivi
nécessaire
je veux vous dire à cet instant que nous
sommes absolument déterminés à maintenir
une activité ferroviaire sur le site de
belfort
cela nécessite bien sûr que un échange
ait lieu de manière importante avec
l'entreprise alstom et elle est engagée
nous y travaillons tous les jours mais
que nous ayons également un échange avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de la filière
ferroviaire car il ya un débat important
sur l'avenir de la vitesse et de la
filière ferroviaire
et je veux aussi le mentionner dans cet
échange le premier enjeu pour le site de
belfort c'est de maintenir la charge de
production et de donner de la visibilité
avec la fabrication du tgv du futur qui
débutera en 2021
nous y travaillons mais il faut
également combler le creux de charge que
vous avez mentionné ça fait partie de la
lettre de mission qui m'a été donnée par
le premier ministre le deuxième enjeu
c'est de diversifier l'activité pour
pérenniser le site
c'est également un travail sur lequel
nous sommes engagés nous travaillons sur
ces deux enjeux avec la direction
d'alstom afin de pouvoir de pouvoir
apporter une réponse concrète dans les
tout prochains jours
j'ai accès direct vers sociaux les élus
locaux et l'ensemble des parties
prenantes soyez assurés de notre
détermination à travailler avec vous à
une solution pour le site de belfort